Make sure you guys hit the subscribe button.
If you guys are enjoying the content that we're throwing up and make sure you
guys hit the like button, if you enjoyed the video and yeah, let's begin.
Hold on guys. This is Rob. And, um,
first things first before we started this video,
I have never gotten into teenage mutant Ninja turtles, but just to say,
I watched the TV show briefly when I was a little kid, like a couple episodes.
I saw the second Weiss, all three movies.
I think the second one is the best one. Uh, and that's about it,
but I've never really read Ninja turtles comics.
I've never really gotten into any of the, any of the Lords.
So I've done enough research that hopefully I kind of get these things right.
But for those of you guys who are members of the Rob cor, uh,
and our teenage mutant Ninja turtle fans, now's your time to shine, right?
Like take to the comments and educate all of us on teenage mutant Ninja turtles,
uh,
especially me because I love reaching out to you guys and learning stuff from
you guys.
And this was one of those chances where you guys get to teach me things.
So the last Ronin was,
is really kind of released here as the story where it's basically,
I wouldn't say the end of the road for the Ninja turtles,
but seems to kind of take place in some dystopian future by some kind of
dystopian future.
And initially here we pick up with one of the Ninja turtles or seemingly one of
the Ninja turtles,
but we're not really given any indicators as to who this person is.
And this comes from a variety of different sources.
The first is the fact that their bandana or ice trap,
whatever you want to call it is basically black, right?
So it's not designed to cater towards any one of the Ninja turtles, right?
Like it's not orange, it's not purple. It's not blue. It's not, uh, not red.
And so we don't really know which guy this is.
Now we could look at the weapons to give us an indicator of which Ninja total.
This is where this guy has the staff. He's got the sword,
he's got the size and presumably he's got nunchucks in there somewhere, right?
So we're not really given an answer on who this guy is.
And of course that's obviously designed to be intentional.
But the other part of that is that they're basically making his way towards what
looks like a completely cordoned off Manhattan, right?
A completely cordoned off Manhattan Island. Now,
the other part of that is it looks as though like with this,
this kind of sludge, basically what passes for water being toxic,
that would it being at some point in the future,
things like climate change pollution,
stuff like that have all seemed to have kind of run rampant and almost puts
forward this idea that the earth or, or seemingly this part of the world,
maybe New York, isn't a lot of ways, just kind of a derelict place. Now,
a lot of those pollutions stuff seems to be coming from this city.
So maybe it may not just be the world,
but it looks like it's one of these things where in a typical post-apocalyptic
landscape, you have what you normally see,
which is to say the more or less collapsed of modern society.
And what came out of it was essentially the rise of strong men in petty
warlords, regardless of the situation, you know,
this guy starts making his way through all this, all this water, you know,
throw basically takes out a couple of, of Ninja stars and takes out cameras,
right?
So this mission is basically one of infiltration and it's looking to kind of get
revenge on a particular person, right? And that's,
what's kind of wild about this because the statement here,
or at least we're getting statements like it's time to finish this or die
trying. And so there seems to be some history here, right?
There's seems to be some history in so far as if this is the only Mendez hurdle
that we see. And the story is called the last Ronin, basically this person, or,
you know, this, this,
this experience happened in such a way to where all the other Ninja turtles are
killed,
but it is a little strange because what we seem to kind of get here are these
conversations, right?
You have like three Ninja turtles in the background and are basically talking to
this guy and this guy in turn is talking back to them.
So it's a little bit mysterious here. Now, the fact that they're,
they're dressed in your typical Ninja turtle garb,
the fact that we're just now being introduced to them seems to lend itself,
or seems to lend credence to the idea that he's only seeing, uh, seeing them.
And they're only seeing him, but again,
the mystery and build buildup here is actually pretty amazing, right? It's,
it's, it's pretty awesome. But once it gets into the city,
we get a little more of an indication of what this guy's capable of,
or at least how in particular it is that this guy sees the world, right?
Because as soon as he gets there, we're kind of given this indication that,
you know, Manhattan more or less as it exists now exists in two different ways,
right? Like New York exists in, in two different forms.
There's kind of the lower city and the upper city.
And you guys will see what I'm talking about here in a minute. But the,
the conversation between this guy and seemingly the other Ninja turtles is this
guy expressed a little bit of frustration in the sense that once he gets out
there to the street, he realizes this place is wildly overcrowded. Right?
So this is kind of an indication that he hasn't been here for quite some time.
Now the other one did turtles are like,
what did you think it was going to be like a stroll in the park?
You just kind of casually make your way up to the tower. And then every,
then they just kind of inaccurate revenge and that's it.
And how did you see this playing out in your head? Right?
Like you're in the world world now. Like you gotta,
you gotta be able to navigate the real world. And that's the kind of thing that,
that we get here is one of the things hell's himself is adapt and overcome,
right. Or do not. Right. You know, like one of these two things has to happen.
It's not necessarily a thing about luck is a thing about being able to examine
your circumstances and overcome your circumstances accordingly. Yeah.
So what ends up happening here is that a handful of basically bikers ended up
coming out of what looks like a local bar or a local restaurant.
And then basically the bike of a woman named Jones is missing. Now,
if I'm a betting, man, I would say,
this person is somehow connected to Casey Jones.
I don't know if that's true or not. I'm just kind of speculating or whatever,
really given any indication here. But if I remember correctly, back in the day,
they used to refer to Casey Jones as Jones. Right?
So do not take that as an absolute, I could be entirely wrong,
but of course this Ninja turtle,
basically there's a racing off of the motorcycle.
But when they get to what looks like this kind of tower of sorts, right? This,
this had building, did they end up finding a bit of a road,
a bit of a roadblock in the sense that there's no easy,
accessible way in where they won't be detected.
And so what they actually ended up doing is creating a diversion and one of the
coolest ways possible, right?
Like they even say it's as far as like snake plus skin style, right?
So like most of you guys who don't know who snake plus skin is,
he's from escape from New York and escape from Los Angeles. It was uh,
Oh my God, what was his name? Kurt Russell. That's what I'm thinking of.
It was Kurt Russell. Uh, but nonetheless, this is like,
what this guy ends up doing is basically getting on the motorcycle, right.
Riding back a little ways,
getting on the motorcycle and jumping it over the fence and into a tanker truck.
Right. Blows the whole thing and gets himself to the wall.
And then basically through what looks like a, like a drainage hole.
And so once he starts kind of climbing through there, going through all this,
this cabling and all that kind of stuff,
that he basically ends up making his way through it.
But notice this like a kind of conversation between himself and the Ninja
turtles, it's kind of cool, right? They're like, well, that was graceful, right?
You literally blew up a tanker in order to get yourself here.
So you can get yourself into this, into this building.
And now you're going to climb through, what's basically a manhole.
He said it worked, didn't it like, that's the only thing that really matters.
It's like it works. And he's like,
and then the other thing he offers here is like,
don't let your eyes deceive you, right? Like this nose never forgets the smell.
Even if it looks different, this is still our turf. Right. Nothing's changed.
What matters is like, this is our, this, this is still our home turf.
And so as he gets in there, once he crawls through the hole,
he ends up quite literally in the middle of everything.
So this is kind of like the worst, the worst situation to happen, I guess,
outside of like, you know,
basically crawling out and into like the middle of the police department in the
barracks, right? Like that seems to be probably maybe worse than this,
but in this instance, he crawls out of the hole.
He's just surrounded by everybody. And as soon as that happens,
we get a couple indications, right. Immediately the, the armored guards, what,
what,
what basically passes for street cops and this particular landscape immediately
started activating under like intruder grabbing.
And the other thing that we're showing here is by way of the people dressing,
right? Looking a lot more casual, you know,
kind of dressing a little more high end,
this kind of looks to be the upper city.
And we get that from a couple of places in the sense that you've got this kind
of dome the stretches over the top, you've got taller buildings.
So it's not like it's just a store. This is an actual street, you know,
with people on it and things along those lines. And so as soon as that happens,
this guy is on the run and that's the way it's going to be like for the most
part, the rest of this. Right. But he's going to continually be on the run.
He throws down smoke bombs that offer a distraction and then basically takes
off. Is that happening? Uh, he ends up getting, you know, or at least these,
these guys end up reporting, you know, Hey, like there's an intruder,
he's heading down this location and so on. And as he takes out this cop, uh,
basically beats the crap out of him with a nightstick as he takes this cop out.
Uh, this, this guy just kind of keeps reiterating the same thing, right.
Just saying halt. But when he's defeated and part of his mask is broken,
he looks human underneath.
And the conversation between this guy and the other Ninja turtles is okay, uh,
is this guy human or easy synthetic?
And the logical assumption is that he's synthetic, right?
That this guy has knowledge of technology, right? Knowledge of,
of advanced technology. And this guy looks at that and it says,
it looks like he's synthetic, right? That's, that's what it looks like.
Like this guy looks like he's just a normal person or at least one of the other
Ninja turtles seems to say that this guy is like a normal guy. Right.
So it was kinda like, okay, it's interesting. I mean,
because largely at this point we can assume like that's Donna Tello,
that's that's Michelangelo or it's Leonardo or it's Raphael.
We don't really know who the other three are because we don't know who this guy
is. Right. We just know he's one of the Ninja turtles. And so because of that,
you kind of get this sort of pink, a couple other officers show up,
realize this guy has been been disabled.
But what it means is he has to basically speed up his timeline because now that
the enemy force is aware that he's there and these guys kind of look, I mean,
they got swords, they look like foot where they look like the foot soldiers.
Now that we've, now they know this guy's here. Didn't one.
He has to incapacitate them as best he can. But two,
because they're being incapacitated, they're not reporting back.
And because they're not reporting back, that means something's going on. Right?
I mean, we already know there's an intruder there. So now,
like the intruder is not being caught and that's going to lead to heightened
levels of security.
And so this guy literally jumps from like apartment building,
to apartment building, going from place to place, just literally quite,
you know, fleeing for his life and trying to achieve his goal.
And constantly being caught up with these guys.
But notice this for the most part, he's able to overcome them quite readily.
Like they're not a huge threat to this guy.
One of the other cool things that you get here is of course,
this is kind of a place where you have hover cars and different things like
that. Right? So technology is full on advanced here.
He actually like jumps off a bridge, lands on a car, like lands in a police car,
throws the cop out, and then commandeers the car.
And then the car crashes through, through like a sign.
So then he jumps out of the car, lands on the ground and takes off running form,
like takes off running for his life. Right.
Just kind of going and going and going. Now,
what we're going to finding out here is this person is looking to track down a
Roku. Hiroto not from here, we switch over to Hiroto himself.
And we only get this brief little moment here. Right.
In the sense that he's talking to this guy is talking to his captain and he
says, yeah, we've got kind of a situation down there.
Geraldo his initial response is, or at least has he's informed by his captain.
It's an intruder, maybe like a rogue derelict from the bottom district. Right?
So somebody from the very,
very bottom who is basically operating in the middle district or causing
problems, and this really kind of shows a couple of things.
The first thing it shows us is that, that the, the kind of cat the society,
which is to say like hierarchies, right? So the,
the class society rather is still intact, right? The lower class,
the middle class and the upper class. The other thing is shows is that this guy,
I really kind of underestimates the various forces that are out there, right?
That you have people who were in the lower class,
who seemed to rebel on not really a regular frequency,
but every once in a while,
by trying to like destroy things in the middle-class or the upper-class or
something along those lines, now they seem to be put down with quite harshly.
And that really seems to be the case because one Hiroto is not too concerned.
Right? So it's one of these things where his attitude indicates that previous
instances, previous attempts to rebel have been quashed quite readily readily.
So he's pretty confident in his ability to quash this one as well.
And he actually authorizes a lethal force, right? So this guy had this, this,
this guy here has no problem using lethal force against basically lower class,
lower class citizens to keep people in their place, right.
To make an example of what happens when you try to step outside of your class.
Now, at that point,
we switched back over to this Ninja turtle and we get a little bit of history
here.
What we ended up finding out that this guy is so called master of the foot clan,
as it exists today,
that he's basically a Corizon bastard son and the shredders grandson now who cry
is I have no idea, right? Ninja turtle fans. This is your time.
Teach me something. Right. Teach me something down in the comment section.
Like it gets a typing, right? Teach me all that stuff. Um, I mean,
I guess I could look it up, but in all honesty,
sometimes I just don't like looking things up and I like asking you guys. Right.
That's one of the things that I've learned from a discord server is that a lot
of you guys really just like teaching me stuff. Right. Like,
and I think that's kind of cool, right? To kind of sidetrack here for a second.
I'm going to be honest. I don't really see that as a lazy thing.
I see that as a cool thing,
because one of the things that you guys have always seemed to express interest
in is as much as I've taught you guys about comics,
like about like Marvel and DC comics,
like you guys have wanted to teach me things about like other comic books,
right? Like there's been times where I've gone into discord and be like,
Hey guys, can you guys teach me about like transformers and where to start?
You guys come out of the woodwork. Right?
Like you guys come of nowhere and just, and Louis was like, yeah, man, dude,
let me teach you day. I think I know about like, about transformers, right?
Like you guys seem to love that kind of banter. So I like leaning into that.
Right.
I like playing into that and giving you guys the chance to basically be heard
and to like teach me stuff. Right. You guys really seem to enjoy that.
So nonetheless, you know, this guy,
as he makes his way into what is kind of like this upper-class and,
and seemingly what looks like this sort of point where he could actually enter
the tower proper, uh, you know,
security is exactly what you would expect it to be. It's far more heightened,
right? You're talking about what it looks like, their police force, right?
So you're talking about like arms and armament that are pretty significant,
but this guy also draws a pretty logical conclusion and says, okay,
like I need to get a ride into this place because what they won't be,
it won't be expecting is a direct attack.
They won't be expecting somebody to directly infiltrate their tower that,
that kind of combined with the fact that this is like military grade,
military grade equipment, things like that combined with our understanding of,
uh, of Hiroto basically seems to indicate that like,
no one's ever really made it this far. Right?
So it's one thing they wouldn't expect that if there's some kind of an intruder
out there, there would be put down hard and fast,
which is a kind of a great way,
or at least seemingly a poignant way to show anybody else out there.
If you try to rebel, we'll take care of you with a quickness. But what,
what you're dealing with here is a Ninja turtle, right?
This is not some average, Joe. Who's just really fed up with their lot in life,
picks up a handgun and decides to take it to the man, right?
Like this is a guy who's trained in espionage, trained in ninjitsu,
trained to infiltrate, to strike hard and get out fast. Right.
That's what this guy is trained to do. And so with that being the case,
like literally every weapon that he has at his disposal comes into play.
Like he just bust into this place, right?
Like head on straight attack and immediately goes to work on these guys and
notice this, this guy one man wrecking crew.
And it's kind of nuts to be honest, right?
Like this guy's weapons are coming out of the woodwork. Right?
So like his Ninja sized Houstonian smoke, bottlers, little, little explosives,
like literally taking these guys out super fast. The other part of this though,
is that unlike the guys, he fought on the street, these are more elite. Right.
They're more militarized. And so because of that,
these guys strike just as hard, right.
They are exceedingly fast and wildly capable. The funny thing about this though,
is that this is a digital kind of looking at that and says like the machines do
all the fighting for this guy. Like that's kind of pathetic. Right.
And it's very, very gutless. Like what kind of a person,
what kind of a leader who calls himself a master has no honor.
And has other people do his bidding for him. Right. Like, you know, what's,
what's the idea behind that. Like, you can't simply come down here. Now,
the other part of this comes from us sort of transitioning back and forth
between Hurghada and this guy. And so, you know,
in so far as Hiroto kind of looks at this and says like,
why is this guy in my lower levels? Right? Like, you know,
you don't understand that I'm going to have his head on a pike before this day
is over and keep sending all his various forces in. Now,
the funny thing about this is that once this guy appears on a camera,
then Hirono realizes this guy is a Ninja turtle. Right.
So they're not supposed to exist seemingly right. They're supposed to be gone.
And so with that being the case,
this guy's like every single member of the foot and bring them in. Right.
So as most of you guys have figured out by now, this is all foot stuff, right.
This city is ran by a guy who's the master of the foot.
And the foot are no longer just like ninjas who exist out there. I mean,
they are to a degree, but there seems to be a kind of blend that took place,
turning them all, basically into cyborgs, with varying levels of technology,
right? Like, you know, like, like street-level foot are basically cops,
the more advanced ones are military, that kind of a thing.
And we'll see even more advanced ones than these guys,
but it's kind of nuts here because you end up seeing, of course the sky ticking,
each one of these guys out, right. Taking each one of these guys on,
and then he ends up coming across what are basically the elite Ninja foot clamp,
right? These are these elite soldiers who he takes out with a quickness as well.
Right. I mean, there's not really much in the way of, of a battle going on here.
I mean, in the span of, of like six panels, like it's not even six pages,
six panels, right.
It's like foot and the neck and then like overcome this guy and then stab him
through the chest and then cut a guy's arm off and then cut it.
Like literally just chopping these guys down piece by piece,
taking these guys down bit by bit.
And then it turns into activate the Stockman tech.
Now I have no idea what the Stockman tech is,
but I don't know what that references. I, I see like, okay, here's a,
here's one thing to understand about comics guys and comic books.
Whenever you see a word or a name that's in bold, it's a reference to something.
And I feel like those of you guys out there who know what this is,
are just like, just like, this is amazing. You guys like, this is amazing.
This is awesome. Like it's, it's, it's, it's kinda cool.
Like if I'm being honest, I'm super excited to read your comments. Well,
the other thing about that is that this guy keeps calling out Hiroto right.
He keeps calling him out, like, come and face me. Right? Like,
like your destiny is at hand, come and face me here.
The problem with this is that this guy keeps sending his own robots. Right.
And so what he ends up doing is by sending out the stockmen to, Oh,
wait a minute. Stockman was the fly guy. Wasn't he? He was the fly dude from,
from the cartoon shows back in the day. Yeah. John saw he was not John sock.
When I was talking with him,
he was the guy who was like part fly or something like that. I don't remember.
I remember there was a Ninja turtles movie back in the day and maybe it,
I don't remember how we explained how we got bebop and Rocksteady,
which I'm kind of sad to see. They're not here to be honest.
I miss bebop and Rocksteady.
Hey boss, this, this food sucks, boss.
Terrible Bosch rudder. You get beat all the time. But nonetheless,
I kind of miss bebop and Rocksteady, right? They were, they were kind of funny.
But nonetheless like this, this guy,
he ends up throwing out like an EMP takes care of the small ones with the big
ones. He kind of goes in for a direct attack.
And that's where he gets tripped up.
Because what ends up happening is this guy just is running at him,
full speed dives at him. And he can't slow their momentum. Right? And so Lou,
they both go crashing through a window and this guy goes falling, right?
Falling, falling, falling, falling, and then smashes into the ground.
Now he does survive it, but just barely this guy's bleeding out of the mouth.
He's like Geraldo, like you're a coward,
having your guys do your business for you. Like this is, this is ridiculous.
And starts calling him out right? Saying like this was not done yet. You know,
like everything in my body feels broken. Somehow I'm still alive.
And then suddenly these guys start showing up these police, you know,
more or less are showing up and saying like everybody disperse, right.
Everybody get out of here. But people are dispersing. People are curious. Right.
And their curiosity, they stick around and kind of watch what happens.
And that's when they're like lethal force authorized. And they're like,
we're going to start killing you if you don't leave.
And so basically this girl Jones says, Hey, ah,
the guy you're looking for went that way.
And since these guys in the wrong direction,
and then she basically ends up following this kind of trail of blood into a
sewer main. But now once he gets down to the sewer main, you kind of have this,
this interesting situation where you have her following this Ninja turtle,
right. Through all this, you know,
eventually located and then realizing it's a Ninja turtle, right?
Like realizing, Oh my God. Now, before she finds him, what you will,
what you get is this guy basically kind of taking his, digging his garb off.
Right. And,
and literally like pulling his weapons out and then seemingly coming to terms
with where he's at, right? The other Ninja turtles talking to him and saying,
dude like, you don't have to do this. And he's like, stop no more talking.
Like if I'm going to end this, I'm going to end it on my terms. Right.
For my family, for my honor, he seems to more or less accepted,
he's been soundly defeated. And so what he ends up doing, and this is,
what's crazy about this. And you know,
what he ends up doing is taking all the eye,
all the eye bands of the Ninja turtles in laying them down. Right.
So like Leonardo Raphael, Donna Tam, Donald telos, and Michael Andrew.
And so the initial thought was, okay,
this guy is a wholly different Ninja turtle, right? Like this guy,
isn't even one of the original Ninja turtles. He's a wholly different guy,
which seems kind of crazy, you know? And then he says like,
I miss my brothers so much. And this is cool because if this,
if this gives us the idea that it is a wholly different Ninja turtle,
this is not related to any of the other four.
Then my question immediately becomes, where did he come from?
Why have we never heard of him? And what is this dude's origin story, right.
Like that's kind of nuts. And then he goes, as far as to say, I miss my father,
right. So I miss splinter.
And so he lays down all their personal belongings and seemingly in a kind of
tribute offers some, some measure of a prayer to them.
And then he in turn intends to commit to Sepracor right.
To basically commit suicide.
And so where he initially goes to try to stop by themselves, he says, no,
I can't do that. I can't do it. Not yet. Not like this, my, it was not complete.
And so we basically ended up passing out and that's when this girl realizes,
Oh my God is a Ninja turtle. Right. So from that point,
this guy's vital signs seem to go flat. Right.
So he seems to just kind of die more or less.
It kind of seems to be the case or the very least kind of pass out. Right.
His vitals super weak.
And then he wakes up in this bed and he's surrounded all the other Ninja
turtles. Right. He's surrounded by like everybody right else.
And it's kind of nuts because we're still not told who this guy is and said,
he's kind of like, like where, where are we at? Like, you know, when,
when the guys wake them up, they're like, you know, we got things to do.
He's like, where like, like where are we at man? Like,
like somebody crashes a men truck into my school. Right.
And it's the kind of banter that we're used to with the Ninja turtles. Right.
This kind of brotherly conversation between these four guys. And so again,
this guy looks like he is one of the original, original India turtles. Right.
So it kind of destroys that theory right off the bat that he's kind of a missing
one that we didn't really know anything about or something along those lines.
He's like, he's like, is this the old sewer? And they're like, yeah, man.
I mean, what did you think you were in the Ritz? Like,
we're gonna do the turtles, man. We operate in the sewer.
Like we've always been broke. We've never had money, man. Like, come on man.
Like, we've always been the guys away, ramen noodles and pizza, like these,
like that's, that's kind of what it is. Right. And so finally he wakes up,
right? Like somebody says like, thank God you're up.
And this guy snaps up only to be met by the arrival of April O'Neill and it's
like, Holy cow, like April O'Neil's here. Right. And he's like, it really,
you she's like, yeah, it's me, you know?
And I'm relieved to see that you're awake, but like who were you talking to?
And she calls him Michael Angelo. And so it's official.
The last surviving Ninja turtle is none other than Michelangelo will that being
said, guys, we're gonna bring this video to an end.
If you are new here to come and explain it,
make sure you guys hit the sub button to become part of the Rob core.
If you guys enjoyed this video,
make sure you drop a light and then we'll catch you all later.
Bruce.
[inaudible].